Donald Trump was campaigning in Iowa
last night and he responded to what
happened in Colorado it's no wonder
crooked Joe Biden and the far left
lunatics are desperate to stop us by any
means necessary there willing to violate
the US constitutions at levels never
seen before in order to win this
election Joe Biden is a threat to
democracy it's a
threat they're weaponizing law
enforcement for highlevel election
interference because we're beating them
so badly in the poll all right if we're
to believe the polls what Trump is
saying right there is true I mean
virtually every poll right now when they
show you the head-to-head Trump and
Biden Trump is now winning uh Brock just
made the point that any Red State today
should just announce that they're taking
Biden off the ballot like you guys want
to do this we'll do this but you see
what that is like it's it's a joke
obviously but it was a joke
right maybe uh but the point is if you
start doing this Tit for Tat thing oh
you see what they did in that state they
don't they got rid of our guy they
didn't like him why don't we see if we
can get more judges in that will act
hourly by the way the 4 to3 court if I'm
not mistaken uh were all appointed by
Democrat Governors um so again that goes
to the partisan part that Rachel mat is
not going to want to tell you about now
I want to show you some of the reaction
from across the political spectrum and
most of it actually was pretty good
we'll start with RFK Jr who was I think
he still considers himself a kind of old
school liberal but he is no longer a
Democrat now running as an independent
who is not allowed to campaign in the
early primary States uh against Joe
Biden because if he even shows up in the
states the DNC which is way more corrupt
than virtually any other institution in
the country and we've got some pretty
corrupt institutions they said that if
you campaign in these states we will not
allow anyone to vote for you uh so the
Democrats Trump is Right are no friends
of democracy nor is Joe Biden but here's
rfk's response every American should be
troubled by the color Supreme Court's
decision to remove president Trump from
the ballot he continued with about an
eight tweet thread but that gets to the
heart of
it